[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo avec une émission spéciale
consacrée au projet de loi immigration
actuellement en suspend au Parlement on
en parle avec notre invité et nous
sommes justement avec Annie Genevard
bonjourour merci beaucoup d'être sur le
plateau de Parlement Hebdo vous êtes
députés les républicains du dou
secrétaire général du parti LR et vous
siégerez au sein de la commission mix
paritaire qui est convoquée lundi avec
pour mission de trouver un accord sur le
projet de loi immigration se députés et
SEP sénateurs vont donc tenter de se
mettre d'accord ce lundi sur une version
commune du projet de loi immigration en
cas de désaccord entre la majorité
présidentielle et les républicains le
texte sera abandonné a prévenu Emmanuel
Macron qui veut résoudre cette crise
politique avant Noël et comme les
députés ont refuser de débattre du
projet de loi immigration la négociation
se fera sur la base du texte voté par la
majorité de droite du Sénat certains
durcissements ont été ajoutés par les
sénateurs les républicains comme la
restriction de l'aide médicale d'État
une mesure qui est une ligne rouge pour
la majorité présidentielle ce projet de
loi immigration exacerbe les tensions à
l'Assemblée nationale le député insoumis
Hugo bernalisis sera privé de la moitié
de son indemnité après son altercation
lors de l'examen du texte en commission
des lois lundi 11 décembre l'Assemblée
nationale a donc adopté une motion de
rejet déposée par les écologistes le
texte a été voté par la gauche par les
républicains et par le rassemblement
national cela eu pour effet
d'interrompre immédiatement l'examen du
texte en séance publique et d'infliger
aussi une lourde défaite au gouvernement
le récit d'Elsa mondangaba lundi c'est
le scénario catastrophe pour le
gouvernement pour 270 contre
265 ce projet de loi est rejeté une
motion de rejet préalable votée et c'est
la fin des débats sur le projet de loi
immigration les voix des députés du
rassemblement national et des
républicains ont fait basculer le
scrutin 40 élus de droite ont voté en
faveur de la motion de rejet face à cet
échec la première ministre dénonce une
alliance contre nature avec laanupes et
le rassemblement national vous avez
refusé le débat vous avez refusé le
débat mais les défis restent et les
attentes des Français sont intactes nous
avons besoin de
nous avons besoin d'un texte rapidement
notre détermination ne faiblit pas le
gouvernement a choisi de convoquer une
commission mixte paritaire cette réunion
de se députés et se sénateurs chargés de
trouver un compromis mais la majorité ne
peut pas y imposer ses vues elle doit
négocier et la droite se montre
inflexible nous avons toujours dit que
nous défendrons jusqu'au bout le texte
du Sénat tout le texte du Sénat rien que
le texte du Sénat mais attention trop de
concession à droite et c'est une partie
de la majorité qui pourrait manquer à
l'appel si la CMP est conclusive un vote
à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
devra valider le texte si elle échoue ce
sera l'abandon P et simple du projet de
loi immigration a prévenu le président
de la République alors je avant de
parler de la négociation de ce lundi sur
le projet on va juste revenir en
quelques mots sur ce qui s'est passé en
ce début de semaine un coup de théâtre
le rejet du texte de Gérald Amana par
l'Assemblée nationale sans même un débat
parlementaire puisque c'est le principe
du du vote de l'adoption d'une motion de
rejet une quarantaine de députés LR sur
60 à voté cette motion de rejet des
écologistes Annie jeevar est-ce que vous
assumez ce vote est-ce que vous assumez
aussi d'avoir fait peut-être un coup
politique alors je crois que ce qui a
motivé ce vote c'est d'abord le fait que
nous re tion le texte sorti de la
commission qu'est-ce qui s'est passé un
texte a été adopté au Sénat avec l'aval
du ministre de l'Intérieur ce texte a
été présenté à la commission des lois où
je siégeais à l'Assemblée nationale et
là surprise 66 % du texte adopté par le
Sénat a été modifié ou purement et
simplement retiré les mesures ont été
retirées donc ce texte était
inacceptable en l'état c'est ce texte
que nous avons rejeté nous avons donc
déposé notre propre motion de rejet donc
en quoi ça consiste on informe
simplement que on demande à défendre une
motion de rejet ça fait l'objet d'un
tirage au sort et malheureusement ça
n'est pas notre motion de rejet qui a
été tirée au sort c'est celle des
écologistes mais la démarche était la
même donc la démarche la même les
arguments défendu parolog sont aux
antipodes aux antipodes eux ils veulent
une régularisation totale des des sans
papier nous évidemment c'est une
position des travailleurs sans papier
des travailleurs sans papier nous nous
nous demandons exactement l'inverse
c'est-à-dire un resserrement au
contraire des dispositifs donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a conformément à
la motion de rejet qu'on avait déposé
voter la motion de rejet on a rejeté le
texte de la commission pour revenir au
texte du Sénat qui redevient la base de
discussion l'idée c'était la fin la fin
mais en mais mais en refusant un débat
sur ce projet de loi immigration à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
assumez de ne pas répondre aux attentes
des électeurs de droite qui voulaient un
débat sur l'immigration et qui était
plutôt favorable à ce projet de loi de
géraldearmanan alors je vrais dire deux
choses d'abord le débat il a pas été
escamoté le débat il a eu lieu en
commission pendant 45 he un débat dans
l'hémicycle ensuite ensuite euh le la
motion de rejet impose que euh une un
processus parlementaire qui est
parfaitement classique hein on s'est pas
mis en dehors des clous des de la
procédure parlementaire habituelle donc
le texte sera discuté en commission
mixte paritaire puis reviendra dans les
dans les hémicycles des deux assemblées
donc nous qu'est-ce qui a dicté notre
notre position c'est le fait que
précisément nous voulons répondre aux
attentes des Français aujourd'hui près
de 7 à 8 Français sur 10 disent dans
tous les sondages d'opinion c'est
constant il y a un problème migratoire
dans notre pays les choses ne sont pas
tenues ne sont pas contrôlées et
d'ailleurs une majorité de Français est
favorable au projet de loi de Gérald
Darmanin avec un volet répressif et un
volet d'intégration par le travail mais
mais
alors souvent les quand les Français
disent on est favorable au texte de
géralde darmana il y a texte et texte en
réalité il y a trois textes il y a le
texte du Gouvernement initial il y a le
texte adopté au Sénat c'est le dernier
texte voté c'est celui dont nous allons
débattre en CMP et puis il y a ce texte
examiné en commission des lois donc
évidemment c'est un peu compliqué mais
il faut aller regarder dans le détail en
réalité dans le texte adopté en
commission il y avait une vraiment un
relâchement euh complet de tout ce que
les Français par rapport à tout ce que
les Français attendent de leurs
responsables politiques qui veulent que
les choses soient mieux contrôlées alors
justement le gouvernement a convoqué
cette fameuse commission mixte paritaire
qui va se réunir lundi et dont vous
ferez partie se députés se sénateurs
pour se mettre d'accord sur le projet de
loi immigration et dans cette commission
il y a un rapport de force cinq
parlementaires de la majorité et cinq de
la droite est-ce que vous pensez
franchement qu'un accord est possible
Annie jeunevar alors moi je suis naturel
optimiste je pense que un accord est
possible et j'ajoute que je pense qu'il
est souhaitable il est très souhaitable
parce que les Français précisément comme
vous le disiez attendent de leurs
responsables politiqu qu'ils se mettent
d'accord pour répondre aux difficultés
du pays la question c'est à quel prix un
accord entre 700 et 900000 étrangers en
situation irrégulière dans notre pays
des demandes d'asile qui s'en veent
alors qu'on sait qu'à 70 % ils ne seront
pas éligibles à l'asile des les qtf des
obligations de quitter le territoire
pour les
débouter qui sont réalisés à 7 % moins
de 7 % vous voyez bien que et puis
500000 étrangers qui entrent
régulièrement dans notre pays donc la
situation aujourd'hui elle pose
d'énormes problèmes en terme de cohésion
nationale de de montée du
communautarisme du séparatisme de
l'islam radical même si tous les
étrangers ne sont pas des radicaux
évidemment donc il y a besoin d'un
accord C besoin de d'un texte d'autant
qu'il y a dans ce texte des mesures
répressives qui visent à écarter des
étrangers représentant une menace grave
pour le pour vous les Français attendent
cela et donc il faut bien comprendre que
ce que nous avons fait c'est pas un coup
politique c'est nous avons réétabli un
rapport de force pour imposer au
gouvernement notre
propre conviction en la matière et
justement dans ce rapport de force en
cas d'échec de la négociation Emmanuel
Macron le président de la République a
été très clair il et bien pr annoncera
l'abandon de ce projet de loi est-ce
Queen cas d'échec vous assumerez votre
part de responsabilité dans l'absence au
final d'un texte sur l'immigration alors
normalement en cas d'échec de la
CMP le l'examen du texte reprend il
reprend au Sénat il reprend à
l'Assemblée puis nouvelle commission
mixte paritaire c'est ça la procédure
normale bon dans la décision du
Président de la République j'ai approuvé
le fait qu'il convoque très vite la CMP
je pense qu'il faut sortir très vite de
cette situation maintenant quand il dit
il y aura pas de texte là je je pense
qu' si ça si ça échoue c'est terminé
c'est je pense qu'en réalité il met la
pression un peu sur tout le monde
maintenant c'est très radical comme
décision ça veut dire voilà on arrête
les fris on discute plus et alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe on on qu'est-ce
qu'on dit au français on leur dit ben
écoutez circulez il y a rien à voir ça
c'est pas possible alors faute de texte
à l'Assemblée nationale et bien la
négociation se fera sur la base du
projet de loi qui a été voté en novembre
par la majorité de droite du Sénat les
sénateurs les républicains avaient
notamment ajouté des durcissement au
textes la droite sénatoriale souhaite
les conserver mais certaines mesures
comme la restriction de l'aide médicale
d'État figureent comme des lignes rouges
pour la majorité présidentielle Adrien
pein les négociations se poursuivent en
vue de la commission mixte paritaire de
lundi les LR maintiennent une ligne de
fermeté il souhait conserver au maximum
le texte du Sénat plus ferme que le
texte d'orig
une des mesures centrales porte sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension le
texte du Sénat prévoit des
régularisations au cas par cas à la
discrétion du préfet et selon des
critères très stricts pas question de
toucher à cette mesure pour la droite
sénatoriale c'est une ligne rouge
incontestable on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas repasser à un droit opposable
par les étrangers en situation régulière
autrement ça veut dire que on fait
passer la politique migratoire des main
l'État aux mains des passeurs et ça
c'est non sur ce point le camp
présidentiel se résigne discuter de la
version du Sénat faute de majorité en
commission mixte paritaire Renaissance
est contraint de faire pencher le texte
à droite réuni mercredi soir les députés
renaissan ont toutefois définis une
liste de mesures répressives qu'il
refusent nous avons nos lignes rouges
les points sur lequel pour nous il est
indispensable d'avoir un accord avec les
LR sur sans lesquels nous ne voterons
pas parmi les mesures du Sénat refusé
par Renaissance le durcissement de
l'accès à la nationalité ou encore la
condition de résidence de 5 ans en
France pour toucher des aides sociales
le camp présidentiel s'oppose aussi à la
très poolémique transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État Hervé Marseille était
reçu hier à Matignon sur la question de
l'Ame le président du groupe centriste
au Sénat se dit favorable à un compromis
on peut trouver un accord on a regardé
les points difficiles laame par exemple
c'est vrai qu'on parle de cavalier
législatif c'estàdire de de textes qui
n'ont pas leur place dans le texte
immigration on pourrait considérer qu'il
y a un débat les LR et le camp
présidentiel sont encore loin d'avoir
trouvé un accord les tractations sont
cruciales pour le gouvernement en cas
d'échec de la commission mixte paritaire
l'exécutif abandonnerait son projet de
loi immigration Annie jeunevard dans les
points chauds de la discussion il y a
l'aide médicale d'État on le rappelle he
la droite sénatoriale a voté une
restriction de cette aide qui est et
bien touché par les étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui financent
leurs soins les sénateurs de droite ont
restreint le panier de soins c'est une
ligne rouge pour la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que vous les LR
vous pouvez y renoncer dans ce texte
alors de quoi parle-t-on l'aide médicale
d'État c'est l'aide qui est dévolue aux
étrangers en situation irrégulière hein
on parle bien de cela on parle de cela
euh donc ça pose la question de
l'égalité de traitement
entre les Français euh dont certains
peinent à se soigner et ceux qui n'ont
pas droit de séjour dans notre pays et
qui accéderaient au mêm droit euh sans
avoir à cotiser donc ça crée un problème
d'équité on sent bien que les Français
sont de plus en plus rétif à l'idée que
et bien ce soit plus difficile pour eux
et que ce soit finalement le même
traitement qui soit fait pour pour les
uns et pour les autres alors il s'agit
pas de ne plus soigner les gens qui en
ont besoin il faut bien comprendre que
personne dans cette question difficile
de laame ne dit euh on refuse de soigner
on prendra pas en charge les les les
femmes enceintes les maladies grave les
affections aigues la vaccination la
prophylaxie bon bref tout ça simplement
on dit il faut
que restreindre le panier de soins à ce
qui est véritablement
important et puis que que cet ame ne
soit pas un facteur d'attractivité hein
donc c'est ça c'est ça dont il est
question alors une restriction une
restri alors oui ça ne faisait pas
partie du texte initial de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est ce qu'on appelle un
cavalier législatif ça ça n'en faisait
pas partie néanmoins le débat est ouvert
au sein du gouvernement Élisabeth borne
semble évoquer une loi sur l'aide
médicale d'État en en janvier est-ce
qu'elle vous a donné à vous
parlementaire LR député LR des garanties
alors c'est une hy oui c'est une
hypothèse effectivement
donc il semble que cette dispositions
soit un cavalier législatif c'est-à-dire
que il n'entre pas totalement dans le
champ de la loi et par conséquent si on
veut traiter cette question de la me il
faut une loi spécifique qui lui soit
dédiée c'est une des hypothèses qui est
posé et vous pensez qu'elle verra le
jour cette loi mais je pense que c'est
indispensable d'ailleurs beaucoup de
députés conviennent que cette question
doit être revisitée on est des députés
qui qui sommes ancrés sur le terrain qui
écoutent ce que disent les Français à je
répète à à 70 ou 80 % les Français
disent il y a un problème il faut le
traiter donc ça ça fait partie des
discussions qu'il faut avoir mais en
ayant bien en perspective parce que on a
été très caricaturé sur cette
disposition on a été accusé de refuser
les soins de de de porter atteinte à la
santé publique c'est pas c'est pas le
sujet mais tous les soins auxquels les
Français ont accès par leur cotisation
et par leur mutuel ne peut pas être
donné comme ça sans inconditionnellement
donc une révision de la me sur un autre
texte en janvier ça peut être hypothèse
alors autre point de discussion on en a
beaucoup parlé he la régularisation des
sans papier dans les métiers en tenstion
est-ce que vous pensez que la majorité
présidentielle à l'heure actuelle peut
accepter la version plus stricte de la
droite sénatoriale avec plus de contrôle
de la part du préfet alors ça c'est un
un des points durs qui a motivé
effectivement le rejet du texte de de la
commission là encore de quoi parle-t-on
nous nous ne voulons pas créer une
nouvelle filière d'immigration illégale
parce que les passeurs les mafieux de
tout de tout bord regardent notre droit
et et regardent par où ils peuvent
essayer de de de d'organiser des
filières c'est par exemple les mineurs
non accompagnés on sait qu'un mineur
n'est pas expulsable donc aujourd'hui on
voit se multiplier mais par milliers les
mineurs non accompagnés dès lors qu'ils
auront obtenu un titre de enfin dès lors
qu'ils sont dans notre pays ils vont
pouvoir ensuite grâce à la loi colon
faire venir leur famille donc voyez bien
une filière d'immigration pour
revenir à la régularisation des métiers
en des anné en franceoption du
gouvernement c'est de dire dès lors
qu'on a un travail pendant 8 mois sur
une période de 24 mois et qu'on est
résident en France depuis 3 ans on peut
demander à être régularisé c'est une
régularisation de droit nous nous disons
pas de régularisation de droit parce que
dès lors qu'on crée ce droit on crée
aussi un droit opposable c'estàd que
tous les étrangers qui rempliraient les
critères pourrai accéder au titre jour
il dit ni droit opposable ni tout à fait
à la nous on a fait expertiser les
choses juridiquement ce serait un
droitosable donc les critères stricts de
régularisation ils sont ils sont pas si
stricts d'autant que le gouvernement a
étendu la mesure jusqu'en 2028 ça veut
dire que ceux qui ne sont pas encore
entrés dans notre pays pourraient en
répondant au critères dans quelques
années accéder à ça donc nous nous
disons non il faut que ça reste les
députés vont faire un nouveau pas vers
vous car en commission des lois ils ont
déjà permis des critères de refus de ces
régularisation sur la menace à l'ordre
public la polygamie ça ce sont des
critères
les mailles sont trop lâes les mailles
sont trop lâes il il y avait trois
critères de veto la polygamie de fait il
faut pouvoir l'approuver la menace à
l'ordre public mais ça veut dire que
vous pouvez être commettre des
infractions pénales qui ne sont pas des
menaces à l'ordre public et quand même
être régularisable et puis la troisième
respect des valeurs le respect des
valeurs de la République qui sont une
démarche purement déclarative donc on
voit bien
que donc nous nous disons il faut que ça
reste une admission exceptionnel au
séjour à la main du préfet alors la
droite sénatoriale a également durci le
droit du sol l'accès à la nationalité
c'est une l'autre une autre ligne rouge
qui est posée par la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que vous pouvez
faire des concessions sur ce point alors
moi je crois je je ne vais pas vous
dévoiler hein on est en en cours de
discussion et en responsabilité fait
partie de la commission mixte paritaire
qui va tenter de trouver
oui je participe aux réunions qui sont
conduites sous l'égide de la première
ministre donc avec Bruno retaillot
Olivier Marlec c'est le président du du
parti Eric cotti donc je vais pas vous
dire il faut faut faut être sérieux faut
pas compromettre l'issue de ces
discussions ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que
euh nous ce que nous nous considérons
que l'accès à la nationalité c'est un
acte très fort il faut pas banaliser
l'adoption de la nationalité voilà quand
on accède à la nationalité française ça
veut dire dire que on manifeste son
désir de de participer de de d'être
membre de la communauté nationale d'en
accepter l'histoire les valeurs l'avenir
commun donc ça ne se délivre pas à la
légère et quand on a obtenu la
nationalité française on n'a pas le
droit de se comporter n'importe comment
alors Annie jeunevard les LR veulent
aller plus loin que le projet de loi
immigration puisque vous proposez une
révision de la Constitution pour
organiser un référendum sur ce thème de
l'immigration et déroger pouvoir déroger
à certaines règles internationales de
Bruxelles ou fixé par les traités
internationaux le texte a été retiré du
Sénat parce que les les centristes n'en
veulent pas euh pourquoi vous accrochez
à cette révision de la Constitution qui
qui qui n'a pas de majorité qui
s'annonce lourd comme processusors
pourquoi vouloir cette révision il s'est
passé un événement je crois qui est très
emblématique de la et qui justifie notre
demande de réviser la Constitution vous
avez vu sans doute que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a expulsé un
oubec un ressortissant radicalisé de
nationalité ousbeek et que la
CEDH le Conseil d'État Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et le Conseil
d'État a ordonné à l'état français de
rapatrier à ses frais ses ousbec au
motif que il risquait un traitement
inhumain ou dégradant dans son pays en
sachant que dans ce pays il est
précisément retourner alors même qu'il
était en France réfugié donc là on voit
bien les limites de la loi française et
il faut réviser la
Constitution nous demandons trois choses
un que nous ayons des plafonds
migratoires des quotas c'est dire que la
France dise voilà nous nous sommes en
capacité d'accepter tant de personnes le
quota peut être à zéro d'ailleurs hein
tant de personnes sur notre sol c'est
notre capacité d'accueil d'intégration
de logement de travail au-delà on ne
peut pas fixer des quotas aujourd'hui
c'est euh nos limites donc ça c'est pas
possible deuxièmement nous demandons que
les demandes d'asile soient faites à la
frontière pas forcément dans le pays
d'origine on sait que c'est pas toujours
possible par exemple en Afghanistan il y
a plus de représentation diplomatique de
la France donc les les Afghans qui
vivent une situation terrible surtout
les Afghanes ne peuvent pas demander
l'asile en France dans leur pays bon
donc mais à la frontière de la France
euh dans des représentations consulaires
ou mais ça c'est c'est très important je
rappelle que les demandeurs d'asile à 70
% sont déboutés hein et à 96 % ils
restent dans le pays et troisièmement
nous demandons et ça c'est le point le
plus important qui permettra de répondre
à la situation à l'exemple de l'ousbec
qu'on va devoir rapatrier c'est que les
personnes qui représentent une menace
grave pour l'ordre public soit
expulsable voilà alors an jeunevar le
projet loi immigration dont on parle est
présenté dans un climat politique très
tendu sur fond d'invective et de
dérapage en série jamais autant de
sanctions n'ont été prononcé par le
Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale en si
peu de temps la dernière end date contre
Hugo bernalissis qui éc d'une censure
simple regardez la sanction prononcée en
séance publique par la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale je vais donc
demander à l'Assemblée de bien vouloir
se prononcer je demande à ceux qui se
prononcent en faveur de la censure
simple de se
lever
je vous
remercie je vous remercie je demande à
ceux qui sont contre la censure simple
de bien vouloir se
lever je vous remercie donc l'assemblée
a prononcé la censure simple voilà
censure simpleev contre Hugo bernalis
qui s'était mis dans une colère noire en
commission des lois est-ce que vous vous
étiez apparemment dans dans cette
commission vous l'avez vu est-ce que ce
genre de comport est digne d'un
représentant de la nation non c'est
inacceptable Hugo Bernal ici il était
8h20 19h40 et il est arrivé en
commission en hurlant mais véritablement
en hurlant à vous exploser les typan en
disant j'exige que la Commission soit
levée pour que nous puissions aller dans
l'hémicycle puisqueà ce moment-là se
discutaient des textes de la France
insoumise on était à 20 minutes de la
levée des travaux de la commission voilà
on VO
mais mais mais vraiment mais vraiment en
hurlant enfin
c'était totalement hallucinant au point
que d'ailleurs j'ai cru que des députés
allaient en venir au main donc ça ça
n'est pas possible ce sont des
débordnements qui son justifié l'
sension est parfaitement justifiée on ne
peut pas laisser de tels comportements
se se dérouler à l'Assemblée nationale
mais j'observe quand même que le climat
est très dégradé dans ce contexte
justement d'un climat dégradé de forte
tension et bien la gauche de l'Assemblée
nationale accuse le ministre de
l'Intérieur d'avoir corrompu certains
députés les républicains pour qu'il vote
en faveur de son texte immigration en
échange de la création de brigades de
gendarmerie dans leur circonscription
des tentatives de marchandage vous
sont-elles remonté anunevar écoutez moi
j'ai eu la
cration la création d'une gendarmerie
dans ma circonscription dans le dou dans
le dou euh voilà mais je n'ai pas été
corrompu puisque j'ai voté la motion de
rejet euh et cette création d'une
brigade à orchenvine précisément n'a pas
été le fruit de tractation elle a été
l'information m'a été donné par le
préfet mais il y a déjà de cela
plusieurs mois donc faut se garder des
caricatures maintenant on sait comment
va la
politique ce ce il est possible mais ça
ça a toujours existé ce que je crois
c'est que il faut il faut pas se livrer
à ce genre de chos parce que alors on
serait de la majorité on aurait droit à
certaines euh contrepartie et et à
l'inverse on serait dans l'opposition et
on aurait droit à rien je je crois que
ça ça n'est pas conforme aux usages
républicains mais vous savez il faut se
garder aussi des généralités moi j'ai
donné mon exemple voilà on peut pas non
plus affirmer qu'il y a une corruption
généralisée et ben merci an jeunevar
d'avoir été l'invité de ce Parlement
Hebdo on se retrouve très vite ciao
[Musique]
ciao